[موسيقى]
مرحبًا بك في وادي النار ، أنا هنا
في صحراء نيفادا لقيادة
سيارة شيفروليه كورفيت ستينغراي الجديدة ، هذه
الكورفيت هي صفقة كبيرة جدًا تمثل
أكبر تغيير على الإطلاق لجميع
السيارات الأكثر شهرة في أمريكا ، حيث تضع كورفيت الجديدة
المحرك وراءها  السائق بدلاً
من الأمام وهذا يغير الأشياء
كثيرًا ، أول فرق كبير تلاحظه
في 2024 Vette هو المنظر من
النافذة قبل أن يكون هناك كمية مناسبة
من غطاء المحرك أمامك ولكن
هذه السيارة هي أنت وحدك
لطالما كانت كورفيت
عملية للغاية نظرًا لأنها
سيارة رياضية عالية الأداء هي واحدة
من الأشياء التي يحبها المعجبون فيها
وما زال صحيحًا أن التصميم الداخلي لطيف ولكن
بعض عناصر التحكم قد تكون
أسهل قليلاً في استخدام كورفيت
مريحة جدًا أيضًا على الرغم من أن
رائحة مقاعد السباق الاختيارية هذه ربما لا تكون على الرغم من
[موسيقى
] أداءها مذهل ، حيث تشعر
وكأن السيارة تتمحور تمامًا
حول السائق بجسمك أقرب إلى
إنه المحرك الذي يتركز فيه وزن السيارة
على التوجيه يشعر بأنه فوري
وحيوي وناقل الحركة الأوتوماتيكي
الذي أحبه هو أحد الأجزاء المفضلة
في السيارة سريع الاستجابة
ولكنه سلس في كل موقف ، لذا فإن هذا
العمل بأكمله مع وجود المحرك
خلف المقاعد  وكل ما
أشعر به لا يتعلق كثيرًا بهذه السيارة ،
كورفيت ستينغراي مع أربعة 295
حصانًا ، إنه يتعلق حقًا بالإصدارات الأخرى
التي تأتي
بقوة حصانية أكبر بكثير حيث
سيبدأ تصميم المحرك المتوسط حقًا في صن
الفرق في هذه الأثناء ، فإن
كورفيت ستينغراي الأساسية التي تبدأ من حوالي
60 ألف دولار هي صفقة سيارة أداء صلبة من طراز كنتاكي ،
يمكنك الانتظار
للحصول على المزيد ولكن مقابل هذا النوع من المال ، هذا
هو كل ما تحتاجه حقًا